[Music]
here's adonis medina getting set to make
the start for the fills his second
appearance this year
and his third appearance in a philly's
uniform
at one point folks expected him to uh be
a big time
prospect as a starting pitcher can he
still be he's only 24 years old we shall
see
as he takes a step closer to that even
tonight
as mullins drives one down the line into
the right field corner for extra bases
cedric will head to second and pull up
right there
so cedric mullins picks up his 36th
double to the season
and his 22nd extra base hit in the first
inning
oh wow
wow that's got to hurt i mean you just
hardly ever see anybody get hit in the
middle of the back
liner out toward left field it's right
at mccutchen and one out
all right every out is big but that's a
big one just to maybe it settles them in
a little bit with trey mancini coming up
first inch off
ground ball over to third galvez has got
it to second for one over to first in
time
it's a five four three double play it's
the 18th that mancini's hit into
this year
well maybe that'll calm down adonis
medina a little bit okay connor green so
again as you mentioned the first
first start of the year did start three
games down to aaa norfolk 15th
but the fills have 16 different starters
the orioles now 15.
[Applause]
that one goes past the catcher and goes
toward the phillies on deck circle
herrera is easily up to second base
off the hands back to the mounds
after green looked him back
he looked to first no double just took
off he hadn't even released the baseball
when he took off
on a 2-2 green buries harper at 98.
what a way to come back into that at-bat
well 98 up and in another 3-2 and that
one is in there a called third strike
bumper car first inning for connor green
but he emerges unscathed
a ball well hit by veleka curving into
the gap in left center and mccutcheon
cannot get it before it finds the wall
so pat felika chugs in with a double the
orioles second of the game
ground ball out to shortstop
and deedy will flip to second he does
just head back to the dugout and the
side is retired all right so two
scoreless for adonis medina
lifts that one in the air to right field
it's fairly deep toward the pole it is
foul
wow that was close
i thought he got jabbed and that was a
thought he did too
bear look at wait hit the ball
it hit the
this will be reviewed oh yeah there you
go you're good luck now he gets it
wow this would be no runs no hitters
you're having quite a year john doubles
uh this ball hit the wall i i mean check
this out it did
right there wow yep you're right that's
a deflection that's going to be number
30.
and
what they call a foul
called a foul oh no that ball looked
like it hit the pole
tapper yeah he can run medina gets it
quickly fires not in time
buildings and the orioles are scoreless
the battery is anthony santander
popped up behind home plate jt trying to
get away from the umpire makes the
leaping grab into the net what a play
best athlete behind the plate that you
will find in the national league yeah he
got blocked by the umpire right there he
got a little ball
a little forearm shiver
and then look at the jump into the net
crashing into that fence
or the wall i should say we know how
hard that wall is
i mean that is just an incredible play
two balls two strikes to bryce harper
and he hits it sharply to right field to
base it segora is going to turn it on
he's around second on his way to third
harper's gonna try for two the throw and
he is out at second base
the pitch swinging a miss struck him out
as jt chases up and out of the strike
zone the orioles have two on with two
out ramona rios it appears we'll pinch
it a 2-2 to ureas off the oriole
benching into center field
martin around third herrera's got a good
arm martin will score anyway
scratched from the starting lineup ramon
urias delivers off the bench a pinch-hit
single to break the deadlock in the
fourth
swing of the miss
and the side is retired in order well
this is 14 straight scoreless hittings
against the orioles but overall
it's 19 consecutive scoreless innings
the longest streak since august of 2018.
that's not good
out toward left center field on the run
is hayes and mullins and it's off the
base of the 387 side jt to second hold
it up there
it's the second hit for the phillies
against eshelman 25th double of the year
for real muto
and a guy in scoring position for brad
miller
and a strike three called and brad knew
it felt high
phillies are old for five tonight with
runners in scoring position kutch who is
a one for two he had an infield hit his
last time
up we go to left center field that'll be
in for a basic touch comes through
real muto scores the throw goes to
second base rbi double and the fills
have tied the game up in one
broken back round ball to third galvez
to second for one sigour to first in
time wow
another magical double play
and again it's segora with the arm
and he lines this one down the right
field line going toward the corner it is
a fair ball as it drops in
and is picked up by santander's throw to
second base not in time it's a leadoff
double here in the eighth inning
to the right side
they throw jt out harper gets to third
[Applause]
on the ground with the infield in throw
to the plate harper is way out
balaka's throw was a strike and harper
is cut down and again right here i mean
he's in
harper's coming on contact
and now the go-ahead run is at third
base with one out and austin hayes
has a chance to give the orioles the
lead in the 10th
and hayes drills it down the left field
line of the orioles take the lead
gutierrez walks in to score
hayes jogs to second
it's two to one baltimore an rbi double
from austin hayes
herrera to short knocked down by martin
and he makes the play at first how about
you richie martin
and he got him to chase strike three and
the orioles are one out away
and now you almost never put the winning
run on base but with bryce harper coming
up that's exactly what the orioles will
do when it makes sense harford's at
first toray is at third jt is going to
get a chance to tie this game up
and he hits it down the right field line
santander on the run over toward the
corner he can't get it game over baby
harper's already a third he's coming
home the throw to the plate is not in
time
it's a walk-off two-run triple by jt
real muto
here at the bottom of the 10th inning
the phillies win it
they win it by a final score of three to
two
santander took a chance it didn't pay
off
and bryce harper just kept on running